let's make Korean style short ribs
oh yeah okay first thing we're doing is
we're gonna wash the ribs in cold water
to get rid of potential bones you don't
want you and your guests to be biting
into bones but if you low-key don't like
your friends just skip this part
I'm kidding okay the next step is to
make your marinade onion pears garlic
chopped Ginger or Ginger paste mirin or
you can also use water soy sauce honey
and black pepper then we're just gonna
blend now just marinate the ribs with
the sauce now you can cook the ribs
after marinating for a couple of hours
but I like to leave them overnight
because they just taste better the best
things in life take time
okay it's been overnight and they're
ready to cook these taste best when
grilled but you can also bake them air
fry them or pan sear them okay now that
they're done cut them into smaller
pieces using scissors I like to add some
green onions easy and delicious and it's
perfect for your holiday get together